alors yann il se passe toujours
tellement de choses avec vous vous êtes
constamment en tournée avec l' orchestre
vous avez votre magasin votre label de
disques la vodka bison ian evans mais
maintenant il ya les valve propose le
forfait voyage en europe hier les vannes
se développe tout le temps quand j'étais
un petit garçon en pologne
je n'avais tout le temps de l'amérique
votre investissement aide à monter tout
à fait apte à mal se passer avec ces
messieurs
il s'arrête jamais leurs portes on est
en train de s'enrichir j'ai entendu dire
de certaines personnes investissent et
de l'argent chez nous bref venez me voir
après le show
on travaille l'omi on a fait battre en
scène ce soir allez bien grosse bergos
seul format que je préfère on se voit
dans la camionnette rené hooft e plaît
mais s'éloigne
vous savez pourquoi je suis là oui c'est
excellent investissement pour aider à
bâtir des hôpitaux ne l'ont je suis pas
là pour lestien ce que vous faites c'est
illégal et vous le verrez suffit tout
leur argent à vos investisseurs
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ou un autre jour
commencez tout cet argent nous voulons
avec circus d'argent dans la boutique
cadeaux jam les walis se passe quelque
chose
non il se passe rien tout va bien si
jamais tu fais du mal à cette famille je
me ferait plaisir de détruire
ok disons non non non non non je dois
justement pris le papier fort mineurs
nous reprend tout notre argent il y
aurait eu des dessous de table ça craint
notre business
vous êtes des rapaces et mon goût mais
vous en prendre qu'à vous et là quelque
chose ne tourne pas rond chez vous
on est en amérique pour la tous une
deuxième chance
kita
c'est ça qu'est ce que c'est